what advice
would you give to a young person today
thinking about what they want to do with
their life career
so somebody in high school somebody in
college maybe somebody that looks up to
the stars and dreams to one day
take a one-way ticket to mars or to
contribute something to the effort
i'd say you should feel empowered
because it's really the first time in
human history that we're at this cusp of
interplanetary civilization and i don't
think we're going to lapse back from it
so the future is incredibly bright for
young people that even younger than you
and i who will actually really get a
chance to go to mars for certain
the other thing i would say is be
open-minded about what your own
interests are i don't think you anymore
have to be shoehorned into a particular
career to be welcomed into the future of
space exploration if you are an artist
and that is your passion but you would
love to do space art or
if not space art use your artistry to
communicate a feeling or a message about
space
that's a role that we desperately need
just as much as we need space scientists
and space engineers so well when you
look at your own life
you're an incredibly accomplished
scientist young scientist but you know
and you hopped around from you know
physics to aerospace so going from
the biggest theoretical ideas to the the
biggest practical ideas is there
something from your own journey you can
give advice to
like how to
end up doing incredible research at mit
maybe the role of the university in
college and education and learning all
that kind of stuff i'd say one piece of
advice is find really good teammates
because i get to be the one that's
talking to you but there are
50 graduate students staff and faculty
that are part of my organization back at
mit and i'm actually you guys can't see
it on camera but i'm sitting here with
my co-founder and ceo danielle dalat
and that is really what makes these
large-scale challenges for humanity
possible is really fantastic teams
working together uh to scale more than
what i could do alone so i think that's
an important model that we don't talk
about enough in academia there's a big
push for this like lone wolf genius
figure in academia but that's certainly
not been the case in my life i've had
wonderful collaborators um and people
that i work with along the team also
cross-disciplinary so absolutely yeah
cross-disciplinary interdisciplinary
whatever you want to call it
artists where do artists come in do you
work with artists we do we have an arts
curator on the space exploration
initiative side she helps make sure
partly around that communication
challenge that we talked about that
we're not just doing zero g flights and
space missions but that we take our
artifacts of this sci-fi space feature
to museums and galleries and exhibits
she pushed me to make sure her name is
shinglu
she pushed me for our first iss mission
i was just gathering all the engineering
payloads that i wanted to support for
the students to fly including my own
work and she said you know what we
should do an open call internationally
for artists to send something to the iss
and we found out it was the first time
we were the first ever international
open call for art to go to the iss and
that was thanks to shang and artists
bringing a perspective that i might not
have thought about prioritizing
you